it's a three-on-three basketball league
featuring basketballs biggest superstars
Allen Iverson Kenyon Martin Chauncey
Billups and more kicks off a ten week
ten City season next month ice is the
co-founder of the league and tickets for
all games on sale starting May 13th at
ticketmaster.com yeah for the holdup I
know you got an interview with Q we've
been trying to get him on the show yeah
I got a show for a while and we're
pumped to have him here but just wanted
to say one thing before you guys get
started I got something to say he's been
working that for months I've been
wanting to do that for several years
80-foot feminine I liked it though he
does like but but do you people come up
to you and try to rap to you like like
listen to this no I mean of course if
they trying to get a deal yeah I mean
you know every every rapper has the
story of you at the club or you had
someplace just trying to enjoy yourself
and some young rapper wants to bust his
favorite 16 bars in your ear you know me
as loud as he can so you know I used to
send him over to my friends over you
like a man go rapping dub see here he
loves I love that and I mean so double
come be like dude why you send him over
here yellow screamed in my ear yeah rap
as loud as you can
Prince and give ice just a little taste
here not not a lot of ice where Brooklyn
at where Brooklyn at we're broken I'm
gonna do it like this check it I got
seven mac-11 game at 10:00 it never ends
you can't bust my Richards even if you
had MC how men 357 okay just to hear you
ha does he get a deal you don't get a
deal done yes you get an A for effort
for sure yeah yeah yeah I like we work
on we work on the moon all right so how
this come about that you were getting
former NBA players to play in a
three-on-three league Hey it came you
know the dream of mine you know I'm sick
of saying guys who can still play
basketball retired now they might not
could play the NBA schedule but they can
play and so we start thinking
brainstorming on how could we eliminate
some of the wearing
here that's you know that's keeping
these guys out the league you know some
of our guys just really uh you know got
out the league so we start thinking hey
three-on-three basketball is actually
the most played form of team basketball
in the world so everybody gets a three
on three game but it's not a
professional league it's not at a level
where people are going to Alina's to see
you know your favorite players play so
that's how do ideas start and the timing
is good though you're going to show
these games in June yeah in the summer
yeah everybody noticed summer's born
everybody know it you know sports and
you got ten weeks of three-on-three
basketball ten weeks you know they're
gonna go at it you know they got a week
to recover so it's important you know
our hard mission no no our commissioners
are Roger Mason Jr okay he was a number
two at the Players Association and he
came over to be our Commission he played
in the NBA him for over ten years I
believe and so you know that's our guy
and you know we brought in a me trash
former Raider executive yeah to help us
you know just get our feet up under us
you know the thing is we started it we
announced in January so it's been six
months of almost 20 hour days to bring
this thing together if I looked at the
basketball players in NWA who is the
best basketball player me okay I might
come play a lick no one could know when
was filed a hell out you yeah easy
he just trip you he's cheap period
really yep Dre look it so good he'll
want to play like that and yellow he has
no game none he counting think he can
true but when you so when you want to go
out and play you couldn't go out and
play with anybody with him I play with
some of the homies from my hood you know
I mean they was who's doing music
together you know I would play with some
of the guys in my hood that can bang and
we got some of the are three on three
games for epic we tore up so many garage
doors
that's how many we used to kill garage
doors slamming into it you know just
balling hard but how important was
basketball to growing up very important
know was uh was escape you know my
neighborhood was extremely athletic we
had a lot of boys on my block and we
would all challenge each other and
everything basketball football baseball
fighting in a wrestling whatever we
could do we challenges of the bikes
skateboards whatever you had one of the
great quotes that we've ever had on the
show because I asked you how would I do
in south-central if I this a couple of
years ago I think 2004 when I want to
ask and you said you'd be cool brothers
got cable yeah yeah whatever yeah I
don't know if I could just walk into the
playground there and then then they
would please they would be almost me
they would be a selfie or after death
can come on man again don't act like
that man come on I mean a selfie baby
yeah
brothers got cable others got cable yeah
when your son was cast as you in the
movie yeah how I mean it he killed it
yeah man he got busy but but did you
know that he was capable of doing that
of course he's my son I know but you see
him up there as you well you know a lot
of people actually knows it's your son
like he had a shoo-in yeah with no I
actually knew he was the best guy for
this role I could have put him in a
movie a long time ago you know he's been
around he's gonna around Hollywood since
he was a baby so um you know he was
right for this you know I had he had
went with me on stage a lot on tour I
would let him do you know nwa song and
then I let you know I had a couple songs
with him and then I just saw that he he
had it so I just really you know brought
it to him a few years ago before we did
the movie and told him like you know if
you put your mind to this and you get
your acting chops up to the level that
they need to be you could probably get
this role and he were you are two years
stop you know he he trained out here in
LA he trained in New York he just got
better and better and better and then
then he end up being the best guy for
the road because it was other guys who
auditioned for the part and Universal
had to sign off on him so actually he
was just the right guy what did you
think when you first saw the movie I was
blown away I mean a lot of this stuff
people got to understand I discovered in
making the movie because I wasn't around
once I left the group in 89 I didn't
know what they was going through so in
researching and putting this movie
together I heard in the land doing
interview and yella we was just
researching and hearing all these
stories that happened when I was on the
other side of town doing my Fang was was
interesting to me so I was like if I'm
discovering stuff and I'm an NWA the
audience they have to be captivated by
the story you look at that picture right
there what's that look that you're
giving us there what's that uh I'm tired
of doing these down I'm outside of this
photoshoot oh yeah do you remember that
day yeah I do
you know uh actually we was just happy
at this point to start doing stuff you
don't look we don't look happy no you
don't we don't look happy but rappers
aren't supposed to look happy are they
well you know we wanted to make sure
people knew we were serious about this
cuz a lot of people's taking West Coast
rap as a joke you know the only person
at the time who was really breaking
through was ice tea yeah so we was the
second in line so we want to make sure
that that they took a serious the world
took a serious and that it wasn't a joke
but you know when people looked at the
movie I think people didn't realize what
you went through in real time that yeah
you know we look back and go oh my god
like it was so much crazier cooler
dangerous all of that stuff yeah are you
do you feel like you're lucky you
survived uh I mean like going the rap
route yeah yeah I mean it's like but
their danger that part
the rapper out is not dangerous isn't
not compared to some of the routes other
people have to take you know I mean
people have to really figure out how to
make it in the neighborhoods we come
from but even concert the concerts where
the police are right there waiting if
you know you're going to use this
language we're coming out here or your
party and all the things that went on I
mean we love to party you did but but
you know the police and all that stuff
man we wouldn't sweating that one bit
but that was great PR for you it felt
like I hope you felt like you know I
like it at the time we felt like they
was trying to shut us down
but then we would want what's being shut
down we was too young and know that you
know I mean we we didn't really know
that we would we teenagers young you
know young 20s you know so the first
thing you bought with big money first
thing I bought with big money I mean a
car but like it was a white car door but
inside ourselves a black car it's just
what nothing like Superfly ain't gonna
put no car companies own plans
I got a leader trying to get smashing so
wasn't a Volkswagen or anything I've
done like a Jetta Volkswagen was my
first car I had a book 69 69 I do
battleship gray I had greens before the
hood battleship gray and would they
leave that car alone in the hood no they
actually wanted toes you know he didn't
yeah it was like a it was a car club you
know bugs and you know it was it was a
car that was that looked cool enough
easy to maintain and you could afford
you know soap people in the hood wanted
those back in the tank I will continue
do you want to play rap jeopardy when we
come back it's not really but I don't
know you should know you need to it
doesn't sound like it's hot but it is
just how all the time rap Jeff like okay
Alex Trebek wants to do rap jeopardy
okay well if Alex want to do it that's
how I'm gonna do that's how hot it is
we'll come back with Ice Cube right
after this stand fashion show
I used to give you grief on the radio
when you said you messed around got a
triple-double because it was a big up
yeah I know but dad dad who loves now
their QB I never kept stats on a
playground you know you must not know
Floyd Floyd keeps excellent stats my
homeboy play kept excellent staff
anytime I had your stuff no knowing you
would get done it and you didn't care if
you won or lost it would be there'd be a
statute and you go what I get you got a
triple-double me I would always win so
I'm gonna come on that part with yeah I
got a triple-double how would you do
like so 20 years ago against an NBA
player I'd be like Isiah Thomas is doing
right man really five nine really
dynamite did you ever play against NBA
players growing up oh oh no you know
I've ever dated a couple of pickup games
okay how'd you know they were like
celebrity pickup gown so you don't
really know how you did did you talk
trash of course you got to like did you
let give me an idea what you would say
it's a gang in-your-face
ball uh I'm sorry you ain't got no less
yeah what else
that ain't no foul I've been working on
this show this particular rap jeopardy
for a while so tell me what you think of
it oh we got could be a lot of money in
this right now the whole room can play
if ice doesn't know what the lyric is
he's going to know he may may not the
first rap jeopardy clue is klockan much
dollars on what is that would be the
person 15 that is correct that is
correct - here's the second rap jeopardy
clue it's ironic I had the brew she had
the chronic the Lakers beat the
SuperSonics rest in peace oh you did not
answer that in question form signal
Conner who are the supersonic that is
correct
right I was - CAC yeah final rap
jeopardy clue for Ice Cube when I'm
called off I got a salt off squeeze the
trigger and uh yes yes - would that be a
bodies are hard on I'm sorry
calling Dan that would be what is bodies
are hauled up I need to look do you know
buddy told me the jeopardy
nobody told me the damn rules or how you
play J it's always in questions all of
us yeah Mon I won that but I lost that I
don't understand that what do you think
of it maybe bringing this to TV show
Oh like I do rap jeopardy hip-hop
squares hip hop skip on squares rap
Shepherd hey let's talk after the show
all right we give him one bonus question
okay here we go
Ice Cube Oates his his running deep
Jimmy can do this yeah yeah go ahead man
hey you see what is put her butt to
sleep okay Wesley yeah what is what is
but it is got add - what is - everything
you gotta move ease coming up you do
anything besides just three on three
tournament here nah man I'm I'm
knee-deep in the three on three um
that's what it's all about right now
just you know I'm trying to bring some
fun to the summer summers a boring man
know it dad you won't admit it I see you
you want a minute I'd like to pay my
holidays ball now much love practicing
football dolls gone um but no man we
need some basketball we need some
hard-nosed basketball we need some
three-on-three basketball we need some
fun in the summer
how about I get with Reggie Miller and
then I just pick up somebody else like
pick up one of my dad - no no no no way
when Reggie just admitted he don't want
to play he just admitted even though he
could sleep out there in 4-point circle
and just kill it but there's a
four-point shot yes four-point circle
yeah three yeah
you know you touching any part of the
circle and it's money yeah this is fun
dad I'm ready I'm ready - I'm ready I'm
ready
how would we do go one-on-one me against
you um I would beat your quickness you
know you probably I don't know if you
just slip in the paint if I beat you
there - yeah yeah yeah you know I think
uh I get a little rough you do yeah you
know I get a little right because I
don't miss man yeah I don't miss hey
I just don't Leslie just don't let's see
you know I hit you love you'd be worried
about me at your ankles me worry about
me at your feet man the big three
basketball league professional
three-on-three basketball league
featuring Allen Iverson Kenya Martin
Chauncey Billups just to name a few ten
week ten city season and it's next month
cube co-founder and tickets on sale May
13th at ticketmaster.com princey what
you learned today
Reggie only wears Jordan shoes and will
use ice cubes security servant get
jumped in the parking lot presented
Footwear Holly rap shepherd is going to
blow up Seaton I think we just got a
green light
McLovin this alley trips been awesome
cube thanks for joining
I'm man thanks for happening anytime the
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience